je tiens à dire que je suis pas du tout
je défends pas la version voilà
exactement cette affaire est très grave
je pense qu'il y a quelque chose que
j'ai envie de dire pour commencer
c'est que cette affaire on y est
impliqué parce que de fait on est un
État membre de l'OTAN et que l'OTAN est
parti prenante et en fait c'est une
affaire extrêmement grave très très
grave avec des centaines de milliers de
morts à la clé c'est pas c'est pas les
gentils contre les méchants on sait pas
un western dans quel sens voilà c'est
une affaire extrêmement douloureuse
difficile pour les Russes comme pour les
Ukrainiens évidemment il y a une partie
qui agresse l'autre c'est la Russie qui
a agressé l'Ukraine voilà ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que dans une guerre il y a ce
qu'on appelle le brouillard de la guerre
c'est-à-dire que c'est très difficile la
première victime d'une guerre c'est
toujours la vérité on ne sait pas ce qui
se passer réellement dans une guerre
même le nombre de morts on ne le sait
pas donc là si cette quelque chose qui a
été mise en scène par les Russes la
question c'est de savoir pourquoi alors
ils auraient mis ça en scène on aimerait
pour noter les spectateurs il est ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler les faits qui
sont passés il vous nous raconterez ce
que disent la divers Poutine absolument
deux drones ont circulé ou était envoyés
au-dessus du Kremlin et tout simplement
d'après Vladimir Poutine c'est deux
drones avaient pour but de le tuer en
explosant au milieu du Kremlin voilà
donc la réaction russe est très vive on
a vu une image avec de la fumée les
Russes disent on a détecté grâce à nos
radars surpuissants c'est drôle les
images on va voir absolument
donc Vladimir Poutine dit qu'on a tenté
de l'assassiner tout simplement avec ces
drones alors est-ce que c'est drone ont
explosé est-ce que c'est une fausse
explosion provoquée par les Russes on ne
sait pas mais en tout cas lui estime
qu'on a voulu l'assassiner voilà Gérard
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour vous
c'est quoi ça je crois que c'est aussi
une opération de communication n'est ce
pas dans la mesure où on parle
d'assassinat assassinat ça veut dire que
je suis à quelques mètres de vous
j'aurais le vert j'ai un couteau là il y
a des missiles qui sont envoyés à 1000
km de distance depuis l'Ukraine il faut
déjà une heure vous savez de missile à
1000 km/h pour arriver jusqu'au Kremlin
donc on a tous les radars russes qui
sont là disponibles pour suivre ce qui
se passe et donc on va pas attendre la
dernière minute n'est-ce pas pour
essayer de faire exploser ces missiles
là on a tout le temps de le faire on a
au moins une heure pour vous exagérer de
la part de ne pas exagéré c'est un
montage c'est comme on a
comme d'habitude depuis le début de
l'opération militaire spéciale parce que
ce n'est pas une guerre n'est ce pas
voilà donc on est toujours dans la tarte
à la crème et bien il y a eu ces menaces
souvenons-nous trois quatre jours après
le début de l'invasion de Vladimir
Poutine disant je donne l'ordre
d'augmenter le niveau d'alerte nucléaire
alors là la planète a commencé à bouger
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé rien 3
semaines après c'était
pescov qui parlait trois semaines après
c'était le ministre des Affaires
étrangères toujours menaces nucléaire il
s'est rien passé donc on a beaucoup
beaucoup de détournement d'informations
de la part de la Russie pour éviter de
voir effectivement ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de la Russie est-ce qu'il
commence à les inquiéter parce que ce
conflit ne devait pas durer et donc
voilà c'est un détournement d'attention
et aussi de porter l'accusation sur
l'Ukraine qui est l'instigateur de
l'attaque parce que dans quelques jours
peut-être on va avoir une offensive
ukrainienne
dans sur le front donc la façon
maintenant de présenter des choses c'est
effectivement un habillage qui permet de
dire voyez-vous les Ukrainiens ce sont
des agresseurs alors que comme l'a dit
ouigo tout à l'heure
l'invasion était lancée par la Russie
n'est-ce pas alors Guillaume Bigot donc
ça ça peut être une mise en scène
tout est possible c'est vraiment ce que
j'appelle le brouillard de la guerre
c'est l'expression donc là aussi vite
tout est possible dans une guerre en
réalité parce que il faut bien
comprendre que l'enjeu de décapiter la
Russie de tuer Poutine est un enjeu
lourd on sait bien que la guerre elle
est liée à sa volonté à lui d'une part
d'autre part c'est pas comme si les
États-Unis avaient pas tenté au moins
140 fois de tuer Fidel Castro par
exemple les États-Unis sont coutumiers
du fait de troisièmement Zelinski
pourrait vouloir se venger je rappelle
que la Russie a probablement essayé de
d'éliminer physiquement aux élastiques
au début de la guerre donc tout est
absolument possible maintenant les
images qu'on voit il y a deux choses qui
sont assez perturbantes je suis d'accord
d'abord la faible explosion
normalement le le l'explosif aurait dû
d'étonner davantage deuxièmement
pourquoi attendre le dernier moment vous
voyez qu'il approche aussi près du but
bon ensuite les Russes ils ont
effectivement cette tradition ce qu'on
appelle la masse kilova c'est à dire le
fait de maquiller les choses en fait
d'habiller la réalité en Russie d'une
certaine façon les gens sont très au
courant que le pouvoir manipule mais
c'est le c'est les fameux décors
Potemkine c'est-à-dire pour faire
plaisir aux arbres dans un pays qui
avait faim on peignait des décors pour
dire aux gens regardez les paysans sont
en bonne forme bon donc on ne sait pas
maintenant la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est si ces russes qui ont fait
ça pour faire croire à une attaque
ukrainienne pourquoi pour souder
l'opinion publique derrière Vladimir
Poutine l'argument suivant lequel ils
auraient peur de l'offensive peut-être
qu'ils ont peur de la foncer d'ailleurs
le patron de Wagner a dit que c'est
offensive allait être un carnage qu'ils
ont ils en ont effectivement peur et la
dernière fois c'est un type de guerre
que les Russes savent pas faire les
Russes ne savent pas faire la guerre de
mouvement si vous voulez d'un autre côté
c'est quoi l'idée c'est de justifier
l'assassinat Zelinski en retour mais de
toute façon ils ont pas besoin de ça
pour justifier l'assassinat delinski
l'idée du nucléaire moi je veux bien
pourquoi pas d'abord il faut pas non
plus trop rigoler que cette affaire je
répète c'est une affaire extrêmement
grave extrêmement sérieuse je ne pense
pas du tout qu'il faille prendre ses
mesures c'est menaces nucléaire à la à
la légère je pense que sur le plan
nucléaire on peut être un peu rassuré il
faut jamais être complètement dans ce
domaine pour l'instant c'est pourquoi
parce que la Chine absolument la Chine a
dit à clairement à Vladimir Poutine
c'est giping a dit clairement à Vladimir
Poutine il lui a dit en aucun cas
n'utilisait le nucléaire et en fait la
Russie ne peut pas s'en sortir
mais là ils sont en conflit là ils ont
un poids quand même plus important et
non puisque sans la Chine il n'y a plus
de matériel technologique et sans la
Chine il n'y a plus de débouchés
économique possible donc la Chine ne
veut pas son boulot là-dessus elle a
fait son boulot là dessus ce qui veut
dire aussi entre parenthèses qu'il y
avait réellement une menace donc je ne
pense pas qu'on peut faire les fanfarons
de l'OTAN et on sait qu'il y avait
vraiment allons-y que les Chinois ont
voilà on fait que cette menace n'a pas
été mise à exécution oui parce que
acculé on ne sait jamais c'est-à-dire
que dans la psychologie russe celle de
la lumière Poutine en général mais celle
de la Russie il faut bien c'est pour eux
c'est le berceau de la Russie et c'est
quasiment le même peuple on a nous on
perçoit ça comme une guerre
internationale évidemment il y a
probablement une nation ukrainienne qui
est en train de naître mais du point de
vue de la Russie c'est quasiment une
guerre civile c'est ça le problème c'est
que nous quand il y a une guerre la
première chose à comprendre c'est qu'il
faut se mettre dans la tête de l'autre
bien sûr il y a une agression bien sûr
ça nous choque mais qu'est-ce que les
Russes sont dans la tête comment ça
fonctionne pour eux pourquoi cette
guerre peut paraître légitime ça peut
paraître extrêmement étrange évidemment
il y a des gens qui sont contre la
guerre en Russie mais pas autant que
nous on voudrait le croire en réalité
beaucoup de russe pensent que pour
l'Ukraine c'est évidemment la Russie
mais le soldat russe ne savent pas
pourquoi ils sont là c'est ça il est
vraiment en danger de manière Poutine ou
pas du tout pardon il est vraiment
danger Vladimir Poutine ou pas du tout
quand on voit ça merci pour le sourire
parce que pescoff le porte-parole du
Kremlin a dit aujourd'hui il n'était pas
là d'accord voilà donc voyez-vous les
Ukrainiens ont monté un syndrome
d'opérations on se souvient comme ils
ont coulé le navire Miral de la flotte
russe en mer Noire donc le mosquée va
ils ont coulé ils ont fait sauter le
pont donc ils sont des gens très très
précis et là il s'amuserait à lancer des
missiles n'est-ce pas alors que Poutine
n'est pas au Kremlin non c'est un
vraisemblable parce que tout ça est très
très organisé juste la France on en est
où là du coup on fait ça dure ça dure ça
dure et on voit que la France mine de
rien on en paye aussi les pots cassées
tous les jours on en parle on a pas
voilà parce que au niveau de
l'électricité etc et c'est vrai qu'on
voit voilà il y a des commerçants
aujourd'hui qui sont directement touchés
par la guerre en Ukraine en vendant on
reçoit ici tous les jours on en est où
le la France de la mobilisation de oui
les rapports entre la Russie
la France on n'est pas en guerre ça doit
se résorber puisque avant de rentrer sur
ce plateau j'ai regardé le cours du
pétrole contre indicateur le cours du
pétrole est à 72 dollars aujourd'hui ce
soir ça veut dire qu'il est un peu plus
faible qu'il n'était avant la guerre
donc les choses sont en train de se
tasser l'électricité
bon elle relève d'un autre marché de
notre système effectivement européens
ça va rebaisser ça va tu auras la guerre
en Ukraine tant qu'il y aura la guerre
en Ukraine en Russie l'électricité va
rester non elle a commencé déjà à
baisser on le voit sur notre
personnalité
c'est quelques centimes vous avez le
content
quand le pétrole est à 78 dollars
pourquoi il a un pourquoi il a un 78
maintenant à 66 vous me donnez la
station j'y vais hein c'est à 78 à 91
dans le dans le Loir-et-Cher
dans le Val
parce que on en parle souvent ici et moi
j'entends de plus en plus de Français
dire il faut le dire voilà qui viennent
me voir et qui me dit Cyril cette guerre
en Ukraine ça nous a foutu dans la merde
c'est ce que le président Macron a
appelé les les le prix de la liberté il
faut faire payer le prix de la liberté
en réalité qu'on donne des armes à
l'Ukraine pour se défendre après tout
c'est un pays souverain qui a été
attaqué ça peut s'entendre mais la
question des sanctions qu'on a prise
contre la Russie était absurde les
sanctions n'ont jamais fonctionné n'ont
jamais fait plier un pays la Russie ne
s'est pas écroulée économiquement
souvenez-vous
le maire on va mettre bien sûr
tu as raison c'est bien tu le dis ce
soir parce que faut dire les choses il
est 21h06 on est en direct vous c'est
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui nous
rejoignent actuellement les Français ils
se disent ils ont ils nous ont mis plein
de choses on va mettre si vous avez dit
à genoux l'économie russe on va prendre
des sanctions drastique pour faire que
la Russie va pouvoir devoir déposer les
armes et arrêter la guerre très vite on
le voit c'est que ça ne marche pas du
tout par contre on a des femmes c'est en
revanche qui se retrouvent et de plus en
plus de Français qui qui se retrouvent
dans la merde à cause de la guerre en
Ukraine donc qu'est-ce qu'on leur dit à
ces Français
je pense que c'est vraiment une guerre
qui n'est pas la nôtre c'est très
important à comprendre c'est que moi ce
qui me frappe dans cette guerre c'est
qu'on ne peut pas ne pas choisir son
camp on est sommet en quelque sorte par
les États-Unis aujourd'hui il y a des
auditions très intéressantes à
l'Assemblée nationale sur les ingérences
étrangers il y a eu l'Allemagne il y a
eu la France il y a eu François Fillon
et Jean-Pierre Chevènement on voulait
montrer qu'il y avait des ingérences en
France François Fillon a dit moi j'ai
pas touché un copain de la Russie la
démissionné de ses mandats d'ailleurs
avant l'invasion et Jean-Pierre
Chevènement a dit mais attendez moi j'ai
été c'est le gouvernement français qui
m'a demandé de représenter les intérêts
français auprès de la Russie c'était
très intéressant ces auditions on en a
pas parlé mais Jean-Pierre Chevènement a
expliqué en 2008 en 2009 en 2010
non-stop jusqu'à 2014 invasion de la
Crimée les alertes rouges de Poutine ne
touchez pas à l'Ukraine n'avancez pas ça
va mal se passer une fois deux fois
quatre fois dix fois et on a joué avec
ça
[Musique]
c'est pas la même chose je suis pas en
train de dire c'est ça ça n'a rien à
voir exactement on a agité il y avait un
taureau nager
alors Emmanuel Macron est resté pendant
6 heures devant lui il avait la
possibilité de dire ok on y va pas être
on va on va on va dire la vérité Gérard
et j'aime beaucoup Emmanuel Macron voilà
la France aussi j'aime beaucoup la
France mais la France on a aucun on n'a
aucun poids il aurait fallu que ce soit
les Chinois qui lui dise si ça avait été
le président chinois qui lui avait dit
il y a pas de guerre en Ukraine je pense
que ça ce serait pas passé
une flexibilité aussi de la Chine par
rapport à la Russie ils ont besoin du
gaz et du pétrole russe oui donc c'est
un jeu beaucoup plus complexe les
j'aurais gagné en trois semaines si j'ai
une ping aurait maintenant une autre
situation ça et donc ils sont fait aussi
peut-être un peu promener par la Russie
en disant on va régler ça en trois
semaines donc bon on va rester
tranquille à Pékin et c'est ce qui s'est
passé les chinois sont restés
tranquilles et quand ils ont vu que les
choses effectivement durer et plombez
leur économie alors là ils ont sorti du
doigt Cyril général de Gaulle a dit
quelque chose de souvent il a souvent
raison il a quasiment vu tout avant tout
le monde mais il y a cette phrase qui
est à mon avis frappée au coin du bon
sens les États n'ont pas d'amis n'ont
que des intérêts c'est très important à
comprendre nous ne sommes pas américains
peuvent voir intérêt avant du gaz de
schiste nous ne sommes pas russe n'avons
pas à défendre la Russie ou les intérêts
de Monsieur Poutine d'ailleurs on voit
je pense que c'est une autre question
c'est une autre question
mais c'est un autre débat là en
l'occurrence on voit bien avec un pays
comme la Turquie qui d'ailleurs donne
des armes
de l'OTAN n'est pas un pays qui a
finalement pris parti et on voit que
dans le monde entier la plupart des pays
du monde en ont marre de cette histoire
de choisir des servants pourquoi parce
que Poutine a fait ce que faut-il faire
devant une Cour pénale internationale
très bien mais pourquoi ne pas traduire
George bouge devant une cour [__]
internationale alors c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'il y a deux poids de
mesure pour noter ce spectateurs ce soir
on a vu encore voilà il y a eu encore un
nouvel événement dans cette guerre cette
guerre elle peut dur encore longtemps ou
pas
les trois mois qui viennent sont clés
d'accord si jamais effectivement
l'Ukraine prend la décision de mener une
offensive ils en ont maintenant tous les
moyens en termes de force mécanique ils
ont une force de char et d'engins blindé
conséquent ils peuvent le faire
maintenant est-ce qu'il y a des
négociations déjà en cours devant cette
menace entre guillemets parce que la
Russie actuellement ne peut que perdre
du terrain ils n'ont plus la capacité de
ré-attaquer ils attendent à l'offensive
n'est-ce pas donc si c'est ce que
effectivement le patron de Wagner a dit
nos objectifs sont atteints maintenant
on ne que perdre la zone rose qui est
derrière vous et bien elle ne peut que
se rétrécir elle ne peut que se rétrécir
elle était déjà autour de Kiev elle
était autour de carcov et maintenant
elle était à Kerson de l'autre côté non
mais donc pour les français
si moi je vous dis ouais je pense à ça
vous avez raison pense à nous au
quotidien et les télé aujourd'hui les
Français je vais vous dire ils ont
tellement de problèmes au quotidien que
ils disent c'est bien de penser à tout
le monde bien sûr c'est important mais à
un moment eux ils voient comment ils
peuvent vivre et comment ils peuvent
finir leur moi et ils se disent
aujourd'hui avec tous les problèmes
qu'on a on ce que disait Raymond on
essaie d'aider tout le monde mais aider
aussi déjà les Français on voit déjà ce
qui se passe en France pour les Français
est-ce que dans trois mois ça va pouvoir
avoir un impact sur leur quotidien on va
voir quelle direction les choses vont
prendre définitivement pour le long
terme c'est effectivement la Russie est
obligée de négocier parce qu'elle est en
train de perdre à nouveau du terrain ce
qu'elle fait depuis 9 mois n'est-ce pas
c'est quand même extraordinaire qu'un
pays de 40 millions d'habitants
veulent être libre et non aucune envie
d'obéir à des grandes puissances on le
voit avec la réaction des des Africains
on le voit avec la réaction de
l'Amérique du Sud en fait ce qu'a fait
par exemple la Turquie elle a pris la
place de la France naturellement la
Turquie s'est exprimée et spontanément
énormément de pays l'ont soutenu nous
n'avons pas vocation à être les
supplétisme des Américains qui livre des
drones explique que c'est une guerre
entre entre un pays 40 millions
d'habitants et la Russie c'est pas vrai
la guerre elle est absolument monitorée
par les États-Unis si Washington qui
fait la guerre à travers les Ukrainiens
ils se battront jusqu'au dernier
ukrainien d'ailleurs croyez-moi